[Música]
ni
bienvenidos a esta edición especial de
migrantes que realizamos desde el campo
de refugiados de moria en la isla griega
de lesbos esta estructura se quemó
completamente entre el 8 y el 9 de
septiembre y es un símbolo del fracaso
de la política migratoria de la unión
europea nacido en el año 2015 como un
centro de registro de los demandantes de
asilo que querían entrar a europa en
algunas épocas llegó a hasta más
de 20.000 personas siete veces su
capacidad casi la totalidad de los
habitantes de moria han sido instalados
en un nuevo campo a algunos kilómetros
de aquí nosotros lo visitamos por
ustedes
sativa demandante de asilo afgana vivió
el incendio en el campo de refugiados de
moria
algunas semanas después vuelve a la que
fuera su casa
with heart
vino a recoger algunas prendas de vestir
para sus hijos un niño de tres años y
medio y una pequeña de sólo ocho meses
nacida en moría
al fin es durante dos semanas dormir
incluso en la calle con mis dos hijos 56
días luego nos obligaron a entrar en el
nuevo campo que ni siquiera tiene baños
no hay instalaciones sanitarias
estoy obligada a lavar a mis hijos en el
agua salada del mar
algunos kilómetros de allí a orillas del
mar frente a las costas turcas se
levanta el campo de karate la
instalación de urgencia que el gobierno
griego construyó en algunos días para
albergar a los migrantes
pese a resistirse al inicio hoy viven
allí más de 8000 de los 13.000 ocupantes
de moría
cuentan con pocas comodidades viven en
carpas con algunas horas de luz al día
el agua les llega con camiones cisternas
y solo tienen baños químicos como
miembro del recién creado ministerio de
inmigración del gobierno conservador
griego spyros es uno de los responsables
de la nueva estructura a lo nuestro
estrategia efectivo de nuestra
estrategia es organizar la población
migrante y relocalizarla desde que sea
posible dónde colocar y desde que usted
me miró en esta isla ya hemos ubicado en
el continente a más de 14 mil personas y
toca técnicas son no es nuestra idea
quedarnos con gente frustrada en la isla
que subsiste si no construiremos un
segundo amor ya eso no va a pasar
para evitar conflictos o incluso un
nuevo incendio a la entrada los
controles han sido reforzados para las
1000 personas que tienen derecho a salir
por día detector de metales para evitar
el ingreso de objetos cortopunzantes que
están prohibidos al igual que el
material inflamable o el alcohol
hay gente enferma que no recibe un buen
trato no son iniciados correctamente y
la gente duerme en el suelo en carpas
construidas mal yo prefiero morir a que
esto sea algún boom como mujer sola es
muy difícil jr
sin embargo el mayor temor de los
demandantes de asilo es que karate se
transforme en un moría 2.0 mejor
organizado pero donde sigan bloqueados
por meses o años
el incendio en moría reavivó las
tensiones que había entre los habitantes
de lesbos a favor y en contra de la
acogida de migrantes las autoridades
locales dicen sentirse presionadas por
la población y han anunciado el cierre
de otros dos campos que funcionan en la
isla y que hasta ahora eran citados como
un ejemplo de acogida digna
el campo de pizza fue creado en el año
2012 por la ong lesbos solidarity hace
tres años trabaja en él el chileno
joaquín o ryan
en este momento hay 100 personas
viviendo acá entre ellas son familias
numerosas con niños mujeres con recién
nacidos miembros de la comunidad lgtb
personas con algún tipo de enfermedad
gente con discapacidad pero desde el año
2012 más de 30.000 personas han pasado
por este lugar
las condiciones en pipas son mejores que
en el nuevo campo car atp
marian esta mujer iraní llegó a peak
para hace dos meses de memoria con su
esposo y su hijo man y allí vivió once
meses y fue agredida por un grupo de
demandantes de asilo como ella
quieren cerrar este campo
estoy muy triste y preocupada por mi
hijo ahí están
af ahí puede volver al colegio sólo
después de dos años en su school hoy es
murió nuestro amor ya no hay baños no
hay común food el gobierno griego
anunció el cierre de este campo antes
del 15 de octubre nosotros creemos
fuertemente que si hay una manera de
acercarse a la crisis migratoria es esta
una de las cosas más importantes que
podemos seguir ofreciendo es la voz que
esta gente no han tenido en esa otra
estructura para poder continuar con la
lucha por la dignidad no solamente en
grecia sino que en europa en pit acá
tienen pocas esperanzas incluso del
nuevo pacto migratorio europeo recién
redactado que termina con el sistema de
cuotas sobre el que nunca se pusieron de
acuerdo los países many people as muchas
personas nos preguntan qué quiere decir
el nuevo pacto migratorio de la unión
europea
que suena muy austral y nosotros es el
nuevo pacto es lo que está pasando hoy
en lejos en las dos el nuevo campo ha
sido construido con recursos europeos
para las ongs es una prueba de que al
viejo continente le interesa que los
migrantes sigan bloqueados en grecia
y así llegamos al final de esta emisión
especial de migrantes gracias por
habernos acompañado y recuerde que puede
ver nuevamente este programa y otros en
nuestro sitio web
324 punto cocina